bonsoir bonsoir à nous retrouver nous
sommes le 6 et 7 avec casta et nous
sommes sur le plateau tp m'bessa vous
connaissez vous connaissez pas l'envers
du décor par exemple la la c'est le
bureau du chef voyez la mort du chef
qu'est ce qui est en dessous questions
on se bat il ya tout ce qu'il faut alors
rien ne dit que ce ver pas tellement
utilisée il ya des masques et un peu de
gêne et le micro de secours très
important le micro de ce qu il ya plus
de 100 ans de ça comprend donc ça c'est
le plateau vous connaissez le desk des
chroniqueurs et n'a ici ce sont les
écrans dans lequel on retrouve le public
et les publics
il est géré depuis les coulisses le but
lui qui les gérait avec l'équipe qui est
là-bas regard déjà tourné dans la drogue
n'est pas si vite après on est bien là
il ya la grosse lourde ça c'est la
lourde jours de siège de gros plans là
il ya une question de l'horaire ici là
comme ça c'est que c'est comme ça que
c'est comme ça que cyril peut gérer les
missions lie à la grue avant appelle ça
une luma maintenant je parcours la belle
salle nous et je pense que c'est ça il
veut jouer tout simplement
ok super là nous arrivons dans les types
qui gère le public virtuel regardez
regardez voilà bonjour l'équipe
les dons jour-là vous devant direct et
en fait tout les gens qui selon lui qui
sont gérés directement par cette équipe
on peut même leur parler directement
attention mais pas ton de donner tout ça
voilà tout ça c'est géré par la bonne
est mis sur les amis soyez ça alors
voilà donc ça c'est le plateau de tpm
pcq on peut tout faire ici on peut tout
faire par exemple là on parle de koh
lanta est là
bien
regardez c'est bon ou pas allez on se
croirait franchement voilà alors si on y
voit là merci merci merci merci
on peut passer à la plage aussi je me
bat la chamade et petits palmiers voilà
on est pas mal on est pas mal mais on
peut aussi si on parle de the voice
celle où on peut revenir sur une
configuration et voilà ça c'est la madgi
nous sommes dans la régie là c'est
vraiment le sacro-saint c'est là où tout
se passe c'est là où toutes les équipes
peuvent accélérer ralentir on peut
parler à cyril il ne répond jamais et ça
c'est la première ligne la plus
importante derrière c'est un petit peu
inutile mais devant c'est extrêmement
important
je plaisante bien évidemment dire la
productrice qui hélas extrêmement
important alors nos missiles truquiste
par exemple nous et ça va nous et tout
va bien alors nous il peut faire des
effets ce qu'il faut passer en noir et
blanc par exemple voilà est voilà
sûrement exemple wallace et est-ce que
vous avez des petits coeurs
oh c'est mignon c'est mignon 1
voilà enfin c'est sur les effets
spéciaux c'est pas non plus du spielberg
va pas se mentir on est quand même dans
un truc raisonnable c'est pas vrai c'est
pas ou faux peut pas demander un
dinosaure une cascade le feu partenord
c'est des trucs un peu un peu basique
alors là ici c'est le real ça va le
monsieur réel
bonjour je peux aussi vous allez bien
alors je vais me laver les mains alors
ça c'est très important si on veut faire
des grosses bêtises là je peux donc
changer de caméra là c'est le plan large
gros plan et là je passais sur le plan
large bim à plat élargi en vie par
exemple au plat voilà il adorait au plat
et après je bats
mais voilà c'est très important
voilà donc c'est lui qui va faire madame
tous les plans des chroniqueurs de série
dexter à côté d'un script très important
fred d'un script c'est la seule qui
connaissent vraiment l'émission dans
cette baraque je le dis les autres c'est
approximatif
elle connaît tous et très important à la
minute où le temps que terra celle qui
va dire ben on est en retard ce don
cerib se moquent complètement comme vous
le savez alors là on a encore des effets
c'est un mélangeur il me semble hélas la
personne qui se fait le plus anglais
dans l'édition c'est manu man huile en
bois avec alex par alex par non pardon
ça va c'est bon allez on s'en foutent
façon dont tu reconnais pas le ton
masque alors alex manu jean-pierre
pareil alors lui il envoie des musiques
généralement il cherche sur google parle
mais moi un petit bout bah voilà ça
prend du temps
sinon tout va mal mais moi un petit sur
fauré voilà arrivés mais tilt et plus
réactif quand on est enfin c'est en fait
si ça va mieux sachez que quand vous
envoyer un tweet
eh bien écoutez il et il arrive
directement à la gc nico qui s'en occupe
toi mon petit nico alors là bon comme on
commence à régner sur le tout le monde
on me colle pas trop bouleverser les
gens sont contents de garder le prêt
quand même un petit peu
est-ce qu'il est gênant benjamin
castaldi rigole pour rien on comprend
rien mais ça c'est sympa n'avait pas
saisi sa crypte de voir l'ambiance en
coulisses
merci merci voilà géraldine ma bosse
j'adore cette émission on voit tout le
monde elle est aussi mauvais que
désagréable alors l'avantagé d'avoir
nico c'est que justement il modère c'est
pour que cela n'ait jamais c'est en fait
vos tweets sont au départ nico et passe
ensuite à l'antenne c'est ça c'est ça eh
beh ingénieur vous saurez tout va bien
inventer pour monter parce que sinon il
si oui qu'est-ce qui se passe alors là
c'est agatha qui me fait mais pas vis
par le mois puisqu'on est qu'est ce
qu'elle veut alors qu'est ce que tu veux
mais tu ne lances à manier tout à bâtir
sa belle tombola écouter ça c'est
franchement et l'âne est là pour vous
dire allez à 5 cm à l'ail pomme parler
j'ai une oreillette mais non vous êtes
habitués obéir quand même coûté son
métier